former USA soccer greats Landon Donovan
joining us on the program
Landon hell's morale today what did you
see last night welcome the most
disturbing part for me was the lack of
urgency displayed we all know sports
anything can happen
you can lose games that's all part of it
but the lack of urgency to really
understand what was at stake was really
disheartening for me and on an income in
Canada it was really hard to watch how
did we get here well that's that's
that's the bigger piece of all this
right it should never come down to
having to score one goal in Trinidad to
get to the World Cup although we've you
know in our history we've had to do that
but I think we're past those days where
that should happen the reality is is we
lost two games at home in qualifying
which I I'm not a statistician but I
don't know the last time that happened
and we lost the game in Trinidad against
the team but had nothing to play for and
so that's that's sort of the reality of
the situation and it's it's unacceptable
in every way and it's disappointing and
we got what we deserved I mean if you
can't if you can't win more games at
home and qualifying and you can't beat
Trinidad in a game that matters for us
and doesn't for them then you don't
deserve to go to the World Cup
simple as that are we further behind
than we were 10 years ago well listen
all these things go in cycles sports
always go in cycles like that
however we should never be in a
situation where we're having this
discussion today about not going to the
World Cup so in that sense you have to
say yes because this is a result
business if you look at the big picture
I would say we're not doing something
right if we're coming down to the last
game in Trinidad where we have to get a
point to qualify we have to score a goal
to qualify so so are we worse off yeah
probably
and sometimes in situations like this in
the long run you know not today but in
the long run maybe this is the best
thing that can happen so we can all take
a step back and re-evaluate and reassess
and figure out how we how we avoid this
ever happening again if you ran USA
soccer what would you do would it be the
top priority for you well there are so
many there are so many priorities and
I'll just start by saying I know there's
a lot of heat on um you know Galati
today a lot of heat on Bruce Arena a lot
of heat on on all the people involved
with this sport let's not forget that
none of these things are easy and if
you're on the outside looking in it's
always easy to pick apart what you think
is wrong so I'll preface it with all
that I think the biggest issue in our
country probably is that we have too
many kids that don't play soccer because
they can't afford it or they don't have
the support or they drop out of soccer
because they're burnt out because of
coaches that are overbearing or parents
that are overbearing I think we're
missing out on too many quality players
and you know that's that's the starting
point for all of it what happens when
you're a teenager and then when you're
in you know your late teens and early
20s and professionally that's all
different but the the crux of it for me
would be to start there and work your
way up and figure out how to make that
part better he's landed Donovan former
USA soccer star how are you developed
and developed into maybe the greatest
you know soccer player we've ever had
developed well I was a little bit and
you know Clint Dempsey Tim Howard to
some extent Michael Bradley was the
exception because he
who understood what it was all about so
he got proper coaching and proper
guidance but for all of us we were a
little bit lightning in a bottle and we
sort of just made it on our own but you
can't depend on that right that's not
that's not a recipe for success so I was
developed because I just was a dork at
school who carried a soccer ball around
all day and kicked it against the wall
and and that's how I got developed but
we can't rely on those types of things
so in in in other sports in our country
that's generally a good place to start
is just by having kids who care about it
and who are willing to you know go shoot
baskets in the gym for four hours every
night and those types of things but if
you really want to be successful long
term that's not that's not how you
develop people so can I ask you a
question yes you can
did you I'm assuming you didn't watch
the game but did you like what's the
reaction you get from is it people are
sort of don't care or I know Polly cares
but what's the overall feeling I think
in the sports world I I think that
you're finding a lot more support and
therefore disappointment with this I you
know people who don't like soccer don't
care about it but the casual fan I think
would have watched the u.s. in in the
World Cup because there was three
matches that you get to see but I think
that there's genuine disappointment
today from these fans who expected more
and you know that's just gauging what
we've gotten phone calls emails and
tweet why's that there is genuine
disappointment and maybe frustration
with where we are with with this soccer
program because I said it's sort of like
if I look at Trinidad and Tobago that's
like San Diego so the entire United
States couldn't beat San Diego and
that's where people can't wrap their
arms around this and say how is that
possible look at it because we have we
have to and in the past it was we have
this massive country with all these
people who come from all different parts
of the world who understand the sport
and so you know we should be able to
succeed just on that alone now we have
resources
lined with all that so now you say how
is it how is it remotely possible that
it and forget about just Trinidad its
how do we not be Costa Rica at home and
how do we you know not do not do better
against some of these other teams at
home or away and I think that's where
it's hard for people to figure out and
I'm always listen I lived it and I was
part of it so I'm I'm careful not to to
throw people under the bus but the
reality is it's unacceptable right and
it's uh it's disappointing I'm you know
I didn't talk to Polly much we just
texted probably what were your feelings
all of it I think it was shocking how it
played out in real time not just that
the USA lost to Trinidad Tobago but
certain other things had to play out in
real time with other national squads to
keep us out of it so you know a half an
hour earlier it didn't feel urgent and
then you're like it's really happening
and then you're sitting there after the
match going oh the next five years
there's really nothing to talk about
with USA soccer yeah that's a point
because it's even for the last ten
minutes it didn't we were still in the
World Cup and then all of a sudden the
next thing you know Panama scores and
you're just trying to wrap your mind
around wow this is really happening and
you kind of feel like you're in a fog it
was a perfect storm I mean Panama score
in the last few minutes on Duras beat
Mexico which you would never expect we
have a crazy own goal that goes in off
Omar Gonzales and the guy hits a shot of
his life from Trinidad and so but I
guess the bigger point is you can't put
yourself in that fits the situation and
that's what they did you think Mexico's
enjoying this well then four years ago
Mexico were out of the World Cup looking
in on the last day we went to Panama and
or the US team went to Panama and if
they beat Panama Mexico would qualify
for the World Cup
we had already qualified and we ended up
eating Panama did them a favor
last night Mexico unfortunately did not
return the favor so I'm sure there are
large slots of their population that are
happy with it but I got a lot of tweets
or in messages from people saying I'm
Mexican and mexican-american and I'm
really sad that we're not gonna see the
u.s. in the World Cup it makes the World
Cup more fun and more exciting so just
it's a sad day I'll talk to you in four
years okay appreciate so kind of yet
thank you Landon that's the great Landon
Donovan the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience